salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique aujourd'hui je vous
propose une analyse en forme de bilan
perspectives autour de l'association de
gauche le printemps républicain et ce à
l'occasion de la sortie du livre
programme écrit par son président alors
pour ceux qui ne voient pas ce qu'est le
printemps républicain c'est une
association qui a été créée début 2016
pour faire vivre l'esprit charlie c'est
à dire la liberté d'expression le droit
à la caricature et le droit à critiquer
les religions
très vite sur les réseaux sociaux le
printemps républicain a commencé à
polémiquer avec la gauche qu'on disait à
l'époque islamo-gauchiste maintenant
dirais plutôt rock mais ce sont les
mêmes et notamment sur twitter a
déclenché pas mal de shit storm et
d'accusations réciproques de harcèlement
avec cette gauche islamo-gauchiste
également le printemps républicain qui
aujourd'hui est une association tend de
plus en plus à se transformer en parti
politique et il en prendra certainement
les statuts dans dans les mois à venir
puisqu'il veut clairement pesé dans la
présidentielle et à défaut d'avoir un
candidat va certainement en soutenir un
est par contre clairement veut être
représenté dans la prochaine assemblée
nationale ce qui des fêtes implique de
faire des alliances avec d'autres partis
de fait aujourd'hui le printemps
républicain est une organisation qui se
situe dans la lignée de la gauche
sociale et laïque à l'ancienne et c'est
pourquoi personnellement je considère
que c'est une organisation néo
conservatrice de gauche c'est cette
question du néoconservatisme vous
intéresse j'ai fait plusieurs vidéos sur
le sujet
de printemps républicain pendant ses
premières années avait un porte parole
officieux qui était le politologue
laurent bouvet qui était invitée souvent
dans les médias de droite surtout au
figaro pour critiquer apporter une
analyse sur les dérives qui était celle
de la gauche à l'époque
depuis un an deux on entend plus parler
laurent bouvet dans les médias puisqu'il
est atteint d'une maladie grave de type
cancer et s'est donc mis en retrait du
monde politico médiatique pour soigner
sa maladie et depuis ce moment là de
fait le printemps républicains n'avaient
plus
d'écho dans les médias depuis c'est son
président amin el gasmi qui essaie de
prendre le relais qui a commencé à
écrire quelques livres et notamment
celui ci qui est le dernier en date mais
il n'a pas le même écho que tu l'avais
le politologue laurent bouvet alors pour
ceux qui veulent savoir qui est amical 4
me c'est un jeune militant qui à 33 ans
qui est d'origine marocaine qui est
musulman qui vient de la gauche il a été
au ps dans sa jeunesse dans l'est dans
la tendance le monde burj east
mais a soutenu emmanuel macron en 2017
personnellement j'ai cherché ce livre
parce que les recensions qui en était
faite dans les médias le décrivait comme
un livre extrêmement sécuritaire avec
des propositions très à droite
et par exemple même le journal regard
donc un journal d'extrême gauche dirigé
par clémentine autain disait que c'était
un livre d'extrême droite qui déroulait
le tapis rouge et la xénophobie et au
racisme
donc intrigué je me suis demandé si
cette gauche néo conservatrice t'es pas
en train de faire un virage du coup vers
la droite et donc potentiellement de
nouer des alliances ensuite vers la
droite alors spoiler je pense que c'est
clairement une mauvaise compréhension de
ce livre que de croire que c'est un lieu
sécuritaire
est également je m'attendais à un livre
qui connaissant le printemps
républicains sur les réseaux sociaux
seraient
très axé sur la critique de l'autre
gauche de la gauche post moderne serait
très dans l'affirmation de d'une gauche
traditionnelle face aux dérives et en
fait pas du tout le choix qui a été fait
parmi elles 4 misait d'auto définir le
printemps républicain
c'est à dire de partir de ses propres
valeurs pour établir un programme et pas
de se définir en contre stratégie qui
fait qu'on est toujours à courir
derrière un ennemi et à est obligé de
l'appui à ces évolutions donc pour le
coup je pense que c'est une une logique
assez intéressante qu'elle choisit amis
9,4 me même si de fait pour ceux qui
comme moi attendait un livre un peu de
clash et de critique des dérives de la
gauche actuelle c'est un peu raté
alors concrètement ce livre il est
relativement court il fait 140 pages
dont une dizaine de pages à la fin qui
résume en 77 points et le programme du
printemps républicain pour le reste ce
sont des chapitres qui abordent des
sujets assez classique à gauche comme et
bien l'éducation la culture
la question du social avec les bas
salaires ou ou l'écologie mais aussi des
chapitres qui traitent de questions plus
à droite entre guillemets à savoir
plutôt les questions d'intégration et de
sécurité
et ce sont ces chapitres qui font qu'on
peut avoir l'impression d'avoir un livre
très sécuritaire mais personnellement je
pense que c'est une fausse
interprétation mauvaise compréhension du
livre est en fait il ya un une
thématique qui traverse beaucoup de
chapitres qui est la question de
l'immigration en fait à 1004 me parle de
l'immigration beaucoup dans ce livre
mais je pense aussi qu'il parle et dont
on n'a pas compris à l'émigration
c'est à dire que
de fait j'ai l'impression que le formule
comme ça mais c'est pas comme ça que
c'est dit dans le livre j'ai
l'impression qu'elle me net 4 me parle
beaucoup à des gens qui sont immigrées
et qui serait une espèce de majorité
silencieuse immigrés qui veut s'intégrer
à la france et à ses valeurs mais qui de
fait est bien est complètement invisible
et inaudible par d'un côté les
islamistes et de l'autre la racaille et
la délinquance
est en fait je pense que en grande
partie à miner 2,4 me cherche à parler à
cette
majorité silencieuse supposé dont il est
issu alors supposé parce que bon quand
on voit les sondages sur la charia et la
république ou sur l'antisémitisme en
europe ont peu douteux et noté un pardon
de l'existence de cette majorité
silencieuse immigrés désireuse de
s'intégrer personnellement je pense
plutôt que c'est une minorité
mais bon ça ce débat est en tout cas il
fait le choix de parler à ces gens dont
en fait ils représentent une fraction 1
fraction qui a réussi son ascension
sociale
également
tangible c'est une partie qui est très
prégnante en fait c'est que ça
représente la moitié du livre quand on
est tous boutabout les questions
d'insécurité les questions liées aux
cités hlm et questions liées à
l'éducation ça fait beaucoup de
propositions en fait est une grosse
partie vraiment sur les 120 pages de
l'analyse vous avez 60 pages qui de fait
directement parle de l'immigration
et ensuite vous avez des chapitres plus
et part donc plutôt axé sur les
questions sociales par exemple
revaloriser les bas salaires de tout ce
qu'il appelle le back office c'est à
dire les livreurs les questions et c'est
aussi un petit peu indirectement de fait
de l'immigration se sont beaucoup
d'immigrés qu'il ya proportionnellement
aux tu peux aujourd'hui ces postes il
parle aussi de l'écologie alors pour le
coup il prend d'europe écologie les
verts à rebrousse poil je les pro
nucléaires et
proulx
chose intéressante il est pour
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
c'est à dire une agriculture
industrielle mais qui ne laboure plus
mais qui à la place utilise ma ce
désherbant pour préserver le sol ce qui
implique l'utilisation de glyphosate
donc là dessus au moins de voir le
printemps républicain clairement ne
pourra pas s'allier avec europe ecologie
les verts
mais de fait dans la construction du
livre à savoir que toutes les questions
qui traite de l'immigration
indirectement ou directement son début
du livre et prennent beaucoup de place
et bien toutes les autres thématiques
quelque part paraissent beaucoup plus
anecdotique et beaucoup moins de
2 2 points communs ce qui fait que ça
fait un livre qui est assez déséquilibré
personnellement je me suis clairement
pas sentis concernés en fait part ce
livre ça te parle tellement de
l'immigration que
de fait je ne suis pas senti concerné
même sur les questions sociales
on voit bien que amine el 4 me est plus
à l'aise avec ces questions de banlieue
et les lui-même en plus issus d'une
banlieue
que sur la france périphérique où la
france culturellement des petits blancs
entre guillemets
quand il parle de la france périphérique
ou des petits blancs c'est un petit peu
une pirouette sens parlant des classes
populaires à la fois dans les banlieues
fois
dans les zones périphériques
donc de par quelque part l'expérience de
vie personnelle des mines et de 4 me ils
parlent plus facilement de certains
sujets et plus longuement en étant
beaucoup plus pertinent que sur d'autres
sujets
ce qui est un petit peu comme un petit
peu dommage
également ce qui m'a surpris dans ce
livre c'est
donc le public olympique elle y parle et
je m'attendais en fait à d'autres
positionnement c'est à dire que vous le
savez certainement au début des années
2010 à gauche chez lui un débat sur quel
électorat naturel de la gauche avec le
rapport d'un think tank de centre gauche
qui était terra nova qui avait pondu une
note disant qu'il fallait laisser tomber
les questions sociales et ouvriers et
aller vers les bobos et les immigrés
globalement
et donc vous aviez une réaction à gauche
qui était de d'affirmer qu'ils avaient
quand même encore une
près d une prédominance des questions
sociales vous avez par exemple un groupe
de députés socialistes qui avaient fondé
un groupe qui s'appelait la gauche
populaire
et je m'attendais bêtement à ce que
amine el 4 me du coup et printemps
républicain soit sur cette lignée de la
gauche populaire
d'affirmer la primauté du social et en
lisant le livre j'ai plutôt l'impression
fin de compte que comme toute la seule
la gauche il a cédé à l'injonction terra
nova il parle aux immigrés et aux bobos
et a dû couler j'ai l'impression qu'il
parle aux gogos parce que dans il ya
aussi tout un chapitre sur les questions
culturelles
et quand il parle de la culture il parle
pas de la culture occidentale depuis
2000 ans ou jeu de grandes grandes idées
il parle de la culture au sens de
culture jack lang
il parle de théâtre de théâtre de cinéma
de spectacles vivants il veut en
intégrer 25% dans tous les enseignements
à l'école ce qui est comme un petit peu
énorme aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'on
aurait plutôt besoin de votre formation
scientifique plutôt que l'artistique
mais bon chacun son analyse de la
situation et du coup ça me donne
l'impression à la qui ciblent aussi les
bobos et que quelque part il y voit là
une sandale à l'injonction de de
l'électorat terra nova
donc ça a également été une surprise
sinon pour faire
un bref survol des des propositions qui
sont faites et qui me viennent en tête
donc les plus marquantes donc vous avez
beaucoup effectivement de propositions
qui peuvent paraître sécuritaire mais
enfin c'est juste voilà des prisons en
plus expulser des immigrés clandestins
être plus dur sur le droit d'asile bon
c'est pas transcendant quand même qu au
niveau sécuritaire on est quand même
loin du fascisme et des heures et les
plus sombres de notre histoire
est également les questions de les
limiter le nombre d'immigrés par dans
les banlieues ce qui veut dire que vous
lirez partir ailleurs bon très bien est
ce que le reste de la population sera
contente les à voir ailleurs
bonne question
vous avez également des propositions qui
sont toujours en lien que les banlieues
sur la question des rep de la diviser
les classes par deux d'augmenter les
salaires des profs pour faire venir des
gens compétents ça coûte du pognon enfin
l'impression j'ai l'impression que j'ai
c'est quand on parle des banlieues et
qu'on n'est pas issue
c'est la question économique qui pose
question c'est comment il va financer
toutes ces propositions
aux questions qui ne tenaient pas
abordés sinon vous avez tout un volet
par contre qui est intéressant qui
aurait mérité de développer sur les
questions citoyennes et sociétal par
exemple il se prononce pour au moins 25%
de 1,2 proportionnelle aux législatives
pour un référendum d'initiative partagée
est plus atypique aussi pour une taxe de
7 euros que le citoyen pourrait
attribuer à telle ou telle association
ou parti tous les ans pour régler la
question du financement politique
il est que je trouve intéressante mais
bon il s'agit encore de créer une taxe
une de plus également il se prononce
pour un référendum sur le droit de
mourir dans la dignité donc sur sur
l'euthanasie quelque part c'est
effectivement la solution pour régler
cette question qui est en suspens depuis
depuis des années
choses un peu maladroite à mon avis dans
la partie analyse cette question de
l'euthanasie est abordé dans un chapitre
qui s'appelle la france qui soigne
quelque part c'est un échec de soins le
fait que le suicide assisté donc je
trouve ça un petit peu un petit peu
maladroit j'aurais plutôt mis ça dans la
question citoyenne le fait de pouvoir
disposer de son corps jusqu'à la fin
mais voilà et ce sont à peu près les
seules propositions comme ça qui me
viennent instinctivement à l'esprit
qu'est ce qui est déjà pas mal et en
fait donc il ya quelque chose qui m'est
apparu mais vraiment après coup c'est
qu'il ya quand même des sujets qui sont
pas du tout abordé dans ce livre mais
tellement pas abordé qu'en fait ils
viennent même pas l'esprit d'abord c'est
la question européenne alors bon je
pense que printemps républicain et pro
pro européen mais il n'y a pas de
proposition concrète pour aménager
l'europe ou quoi que ce soit
c'est un petit peu un type étrange et
surtout il ya un gros point aveugle qui
est la question économique
donc la question de la vie des
entreprises etc est abordé à travers la
question sociale des bas salaires qui
pourrait valoriser etc mais la question
de l'entreprise des choix stratégiques
de développement de la france est-ce
qu'on veut ré industrialiser
quelle industrie du futur
veut
contribuer le développement enfin
toutes ces questions qui sont
réellement celle de
l'économie réelle ne sont pas abordés il
n'y a pas de chapitre du tout dessus on
sait pas du tout quelle est la position
du parti républicain c'est étonnant
parce que vont amener de 4000 vient donc
de la gauche montebourg gist on aurait
pu s'attendre à au moins deux coups de
position sur la souveraineté économique
ou sur l'appareil productif
et pour le coup il ya vraiment du coup
rien du tout là dessus c'est assez
c'est assez surprenant quand on en prend
prend conscience moi j'ai deux trois
jours at il dit est que c'était absents
tellement tellement tellement s'en parle
pas
donc voilà pour les livres en fin de
compte des propositions de centre gauche
dure
que je qualifierais de vals east
mais qui ne sont pas aussi sécuritaires
que ça et qui marque beaucoup moins que
ce à quoi je m'attendais un décalage du
printemps républicain vers la droite
donc quelque part personnellement une
petite déception
maintenant passons au printemps
républicain en tant qu'association est
peut-être en tant que futur parti
politique aujourd'hui
donc avec ce livre programme de fête le
printemps républicains ne confirme qu'il
est de centre gauche de tendance valls
east quelque part le dernier carré à
vals east indépendant et qui se situe
donc quelque part entre le ps et le
public en marche ce qui de fait limite
ses alliances potentielles puisque bon
sur l'écologie déjà ne pourra pas
s'allier avec la gauche de la gauche les
seuls en théorie à la gauche de la
gauche et qu'il pourrait s'associer
c'est parti communiste vu ses positions
mais bon qui aujourd'hui envie de
s'allier avec le parti communiste et la
bonne question est donc tout ça ça pose
la question vient de l'arrêt l'influencé
que peut avoir le printemps républicain
et
si la question de sa survie
lorsque s'allie avec le parti socialiste
c'est effectivement pouvoir avoir
potentiellement des alliances avec
peut-être on sait pas trop des élus
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'état du ps on
sait pas du tout ce que pourront donner
les prochaines législatives pour lui et
de l'autre côté s'allier avec la
république en marche c'est se condamner
à être un espèce de groupuscules à la
remorque du groupe parti et à se
condamner à voir quelques strapontins
mais dans ce cas là ça se condamne
condamne aussi allier son existence à
celle du groupe partie parce que
généralement dans cette situation là on
l'a bien vu souvent avec le modem ou les
petits partis centristes quand le groupe
arctic élections alliés se casse la
gueule c'est fini
d'ailleurs il ya déjà eu un précédent
historique 1 2 de gauche comme ça
centriste qui s'allie avec la droite
pendant l'ère sarkozy quand sarkozy est
élu président en 2007 il avait ouvert
des des postes au centre gauche s'est en
effet fait venir quelques uns notamment
jean-marie bockel qui avait créé un
petit groupe un petit parti qui
s'appelait la la gauche moderne
et cette gauche moderne qui était en fin
de compte valls east avant l'heure a
sombré corps et biens avec avec le
sarkozysme et puis il ya aussi la
question qui est celle de la question de
l' influence aujourd'hui du printemps
républicain avec ou sans alliance
aujourd'hui l'association c'est 1500
personnes d'après minel 4 me ce qui ce
qui est quasiment rien c'est d'un point
de vue d'un parti c'est un groupuscule
l'équivalent du npa
est ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui de la place
de fête avec des alliances ou sans
alliance pour l'existence de cette
gauche centristes néo conservatrice où
valsent east c'est une très bonne
question
alors j'aurais aimé avoir une réponse
indirecte notamment avec
les chiffres de vente de ce livre mais
la personne à qui j'ai demandé m'a
pas répondu à l'heure actuelle donc si
un jour elle répond je mettrai les
chiffres en descriptions parce que ça
donne quand même un début de piste pour
savoir quelle influence réelle de ce
genre d'organisation
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
j'ai une piste indirecte à savoir que ce
livre j'ai acheté d'occasion sur un
grand sites culturels d'occasion
allemands dont je ne citerai pas le nom
et un mois après la sortie
je les ai eus à 50% du prix initial ce
qui n'est pas très bon signe
généralement les livres sur ce site se
retrouve plutôt à moins 10 - 20 voire au
pire - 30 % quand ils sont comme ça dans
l'actualité qui vient de sortir là qu'il
est déjà le prix divisé par deux sa
indique quand même qui a pas forcément
beaucoup de demandes et qu'ils en ont
exemple trop trop en stock
ça en dit mon avis un petit peut avoir
un petit peu long sur l'influencé réelle
et l'intérêt qu'on peut avoir dans
l'opinion sur pour pour le printemps
républicain et pour cette position
politique mais j'ai pas plus de chiffres
que ça
bref c'est tout pour cette vidéo c'est
vous intéressé n'hésitez pas à la
partager et vous éloigner à la chaîne et
sur ce je vous dis à la prochaine